the movie begins with a voice narrating
about a mythical shark off the Baja
Coast Mexico the legend addresses this
creature as the black demon that appears
only when it's summoned the scene then
cuts to an oil rig platform owned by
Nixon oil company located in the middle
of the sea two workers are on a boat
near the rig preparing to carry out some
instructed tasks one of them named nacho
dives into the water and places a bomb
on the site as he attempts to swim back
to the boat he is suddenly attacked and
devoured by a mysterious creature his
partner on the boat feels the Tremors
and tries to contact nacho when he
doesn't receive any response he turns on
the lights on the boat to help nacho
find his way up however in doing so he
signs his own death sentence as the
creature tracks him down and eats him
alive he didn't taste as good as nacho
though in the next scene we are
introduced to a Nixon Oil Company
inspector Paul Sturgis who is sent to a
small Mexican Town to check on lamante
an offshore oil rig he brings his wife
enus and their two children Audrey and
Tommy along for a vacation upon arrival
the family finds the town in Ruins and
the remaining locals are suspicious and
unfriendly Paul drives to the same hotel
where he and his wife stayed for their
honeymoon 16 years ago however they find
that the hotel is closed so Paul goes to
talk to some locals and asks about
restaurants nearby one of the locals
named Ry suspects that he works for an
oil industry because the place isn't a
tourist town just that then Enz
intervenes and talks to the man in their
native language realizing that the woman
is Mexican Ray decides to help them and
leads them to a restaurant on their way
the family spots a shrine that is
dedicated to talok the Aztec god which
Reay claims to be an altar erected for
protection of the residents he also
tells them that there's a creature in
the sea which the natives address as El
demono however the family dismisses it
as a mere tale and enters the restaurant
not long after Paul receives a call from
work asking him to to carry out the
immediate inspection to see if the rig
is worth revitalizing or decommissioning
as a result Paul leaves assuring his
family that he'll be back before Sunset
he then rents a boat and makes his way
to the rig while sailing he inquires
with the Sailor about what happened to
the city the ladder reveals that the
people have abandoned the town due to
fear of el demono upon reaching a
distance the Sailor pulls over and asks
Paul to proceed the rest of the journey
alone as he seems to be afraid of going
near the rig back at the restaurant the
family is approached by a drunk local
gang member who starts to harass Audrey
in an effort to protect her daughter
enas smashes a beer bottle over the ass
salent head and brandishes The Shard as
a threat before escaping with her
children the trio tries to get in their
car but learns that the Gang has
punctured the tires left with no choice
enas takes her children to the seashore
and pays a sailor to transport them to
the oil rig drunk gangsters or sea
demons I'd have picked the other side
meanwhile Paul arrives at the rig to
find finded in a state of disrepair
marked by hazards and surrounded by an
oil spill he also finds some diving
equipment stained with blood despite
this he is unfazed and goes ahead to
finish his work once there he begins to
call for his colleague but no one
answers as he enters a room he is
cornered by two men chato and Junior
before they can attack him Paul explains
that he's the inspector sent by Nixon
oil as a result the two men lower their
weapons and reveal that they're the only
surviving crew members with the rest
having been killed puzzled Paul attempts
to inquire further but their
conversation is suddenly interrupted by
the sound of an approaching boat it is
none other than his own family as the
boat nears chato and Junior begin to
panic and fire flares in order to
distract the so-called El demono at the
same time Paul notices his boat sinking
and doesn't understand what's going on
eventually his family makes it safely to
the rig while getting off the boat
Audrey accidentally falls into the water
and during this time she witnessed is
several human limbs floating after being
rescued the girl tells her father about
what she just saw but he dismisses her
saying she must have been confused
because of the spreading oil in the
meantime the Sailor sails away at high
speed unaware of the imminent danger at
the same time Paul and inas demand
answers to What's Happening so chatau
hands them binoculars to watch The
Returning sailor to their horror they
witness a giant 70 ton Megalodon
devouring the entire boat this turns out
to be the same creature that the locals
address as the black demon and El demono
in Spanish in the aftermath enas is so
overwhelmed with guilt for the Sailor
because she was the one who convinced
him to bring them to the rig however
Paul consoles her saying it wasn't her
fault even though it was later while
discussing the creature chatau reveals
to Paul that the calls made to nixen oil
for help were ignored and now the radio
on the rig doesn't function due to the
numerous attacks on the facility upon
learning that there's no electricity
here Paul comes up with a plan to dive
into the water repair the electric
cables and subsequently fix the
communication system while preparing to
execute their plan chato reveals a
theory regarding the black demon he says
that talok the god of rain sent this
black demon to punish Humanity for
depleting natural resources additionally
he claims that this demonic creature
makes people see things and plays with
their minds Paul doesn't believe this
story at all and even yet yells at him
for filling his children's heads with
these superstitions Paul is even more in
denial than Kevin spacy following this
chatau and Junior head into the water in
a diving capsule while Paul watches them
through a handheld device as they reach
a certain depth the two dive into the
ocean to investigate the power supply
issue soon after they discover the time
bomb that nacho attached to a leg of the
rig which makes them realize that the
rig will explode in the next few hours
during their exploration chato
experiences is a sudden vision of human
body parts floating around him realizing
that the black demon is near he hastily
swims back into the capsule Junior
attempts to follow suit but the
Megalodon grabs the capsule and starts
pulling it downward seeing this Paul
somehow manages to pull the capsule up
but only chatau manages to return back
alive moments later Junior's body floats
in the water his legs have been
gruesomely devoured he has become a
junior junior Audrey Witnesses this from
the window which freaks her out however
she tries to remain calm in front of her
little brother after losing a member of
his group Paul realizes the gravity of
the situation seeing enas crying he
tries to console her assuring that he'll
do anything to save his family from that
demon Paul then goes to chato and
expresses his apology for his loss while
they are talking he notices some ships
so he quickly grabs a flare gun and
fires it to catch their attention but
before he wastes the second shot chato
seizes the gun from his hand and claims
that there is no sh ship he reminds him
that El demano makes them see things and
messes with their minds hell not 10
minutes ago he thought Paul was
Elmo however Paul dismisses the
existence of talok as a mere
Superstition this infuriates chato who
then punches him in the face before they
can get into a brawl though enas steps
in and separates them later on Paul
comes up with a new idea to regenerate
the electricity for this he goes looking
for waterways to reroute the cooling
system despite their earlier
disagreement chatau tries to be friendly
with Paul and joins him for assistance
meanwhile in begins Scavenging the rig
in hopes of finding something useful
during this she discovers several safety
reports that reveal numerous ignored
warnings she further finds out that Paul
signed the documents approving the rig's
revitalization despite being aware of
these dangerous conditions at the same
time Tommy goes to the edge of the rig
to play When the black demon suddenly
launches its attack this causes the
little boy to fall in into the water and
he lets out a loud scream oh
my hearing this inas rushes to jump into
the water while Paul also Dives to
distract the creature soon after Audrey
throws a life buoy to pull her mother
and brother in when Paul realizes that
his family is safe he swims back to the
platform barely managing to escape the
Megalodon's attack in the aftermath of
this incident enas confronts her husband
to better findings now that he's caught
in his wrongdoing he admits his mistakes
and adds that he did what he did to
provide financial support for his family
he also states that his job and economic
security would be at risk if he did not
act according to the company's interests
enas can't hide her disappointment and
blames him for all the deaths as a
result she calls him a Monster who
risked everyone's lives for his personal
gain hearing this Paul regrets
everything he did but it's too late to
make things right as the bomb explodes
in less than an hour burdened by guilt
he later confesses to chato about
everything he has done in the past it
was his first year working at Nixon oil
when he came across the company's first
irregularity after surveying the
facility Paul submitted his report
including all the dangers and
deficiencies he had found however his
Executives instructed him to overlook
the problems and make a false report
when he hesitated the company threatened
to fire him and hire another worker to
do his job since enas was pregnant at
that time he couldn't afford losing his
job so he reluctantly manipulated his
report ever since has been forced to
work in Nixon oil's self-interest while
the local community suffered due to the
company's negligence and greed seeing
the bomb Paul now realizes that Nixon
oil had been intending to blow him up
along with the entire rig because they
fear that their practices will be
exposed and that they might be blamed
for the oil spill determined not to
allow his family to suffer for the
mistakes he committed Paul devises a
plan to get them out he decides to dive
into the water and take the bomb away
while also luring the shark in this way
they can buy them enough time to flee
the scene meanwhile Tommy and Audrey are
seen constructing a makeshift dinghy
with life jackets to facilitate their
escape Paul shares his decision with his
wife and also offers a sincere apology
for the grave mistake that he made upon
learning about the risk involved in this
plan enas gets worried for her husband
but he says that he must take this step
to rectify his mistakes he didn't feel
guilty until she got mad at him but now
he's really guilty after this he makes
chato promise that he'll take his family
to safety Paul then Dawns his suit and
dives into the ocean while chato takes
all of them to the dinghy Paul soon
comes across the bomb and notices that
only 5 minutes are left before
detonation at this point he realizes
that he won't be able to escape before
the explosion so he wraps the bomb
around his body and decides to sacrifice
himself to kill the creature in the last
few minutes Paul hides in a structure of
the rig and contacts his family through
his radio he apologizes to his wife one
last time encourages his children to
stay strong and wishes them luck in
their future Paul also apologizes to
chato for the harm he caused to his
Town's people in addition he tells him
that he has left some documents in his
bag so that he can hold Nixon oil
accountable even though that'll probably
bankrupt his family or something after
bidding his final goodbyes to everyone
Paul swims out and lets the Megalodon
devour him moments later the bomb
detonates ultim itely killing the black
demon and causing the rig to collapse
the family witnessing the explosion from
a distance is devastated but Ina still
tries to stay strong in front of her
children as they sail away they are
eventually rescued by a fishing boat the
movie ends as a rainstorm begins
symbolizing the potential forgiveness of
mankind by the god of rain subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching